So it seems like we sort of can't just have
a normal weekend.
The latest is that the Demoine register canceled
the release of the last Iowa primary poll
before today's caucus in Iowa.
But in the poll that did come out, Bernie
Sanders has jumped to a 13 point advantage
over Joe Biden with Elizabeth Warren and second
place, seven points behind Bernie.
So let's take it as, I love to do a step at
a time tonight is the Iowa caucuses.
These are the first votes in the 2020 democratic
primary.
It is not a primary.
So instead of you just, you show up at any
time during the day and you vote and then
you leave.
The way the caucus works is people gather,
they talk about the candidates, they try to
convince other voters come over and support
my candidate and then they take an initial
vote.
The viability threshold in the Iowa caucuses
is 15% so if you take that initial vote and
your candidate is below 15% in any precinct,
then you have another round of discussion
and you select another candidate until everybody
remaining has 15% and then the delegates are
allocated proportionately.
That's the gist of the way the caucus system
works.
The Des Moines register poll is considered
the gold standard Iowa poll and they announced
over the weekend, we're not releasing the
poll results because at least one person who
was surveyed said one of the candidates was
not mentioned.
When they said of the following candidates,
who do you support?
A candidate was left out.
Uh, the Des Moines register said, we don't
have evidence that this happened to more than
one person, but we don't have proof that it
didn't.
And so we are canceling the release of the
poll and many people immediately an understandably
very suspicious that this was done either
because Bernie was crushing the results and
they wanted to suppress it or because Bernie
was the one who wasn't mentioned in the list
of candidates.
We don't know if that's true, but it is immediately
raising suspicions and the temperature of
this entire thing has just increased dramatically
hours before the caucusing starts tonight.
Now, meanwhile, there are other polls.
We have a civics DPR or DFP data for progress
poll and the numbers heavily favor Bernie
Sanders.
Bernie 28 Warren, 21 Biden and booed edge
edge tied at 15 in an average of recent Iowa
polls going into today's vote, the numbers
are Bernie leading at 24.7 Biden at 21 booted
judge at 16 and Warren 15 now with these numbers,
remember there is proportional allocation
of delegates with these percentages.
You would have Bernie get 10 delegates from
Iowa.
You would have Biden get nine Buddha judged
seven Warren six but remember there's a 15%
viability threshold.
So there's recently, there's a roughly a quarter
of the vote that right now is with candidates
that are below 15% that support will be reallocated
to the other candidates before the night is
over.
Meaning anyone still could win.
But the most important takeaway, and I don't
want people to forget this, almost anyone
can come away with the most delegates tonight
or with a plurality of the delegates tonight,
but no one is going to do better than get
some momentum because there's only 41 delegates
tonight.
So if Bernie gets nine and Biden gets 10 or
Bernie gets 11 and Biden gets eight, this
is almost zero in context of the entire democratic
primary.
That's not to say it doesn't matter tonight.
The point is tonight is more about momentum
because getting one more delegate than the
second place person.
In terms of the math, that doesn't do much
in terms of the headlines.
In terms of the PR, it does a lot.
So we will have live coverage on our YouTube
channel, on our Twitch channel, and on our
Facebook page tonight.
I hope you'll join.
We'll be watching the results coming in.
We'll be taking live calls.
I will be, I think I actually have a bunch
of stuff to give away.
Also, we've got a bunch of stuff that we've
accumulated from different advertisers and
sponsors.
I'm going to have stuff to give away.
Uh, if you live in Iowa, go caucus.
Call into the show afterwards.
I will want to hear from you and make sure
you're following me on Twitter at the Pacman.
If you experience any irregularities when
you go caucus
and I in Iowa, send me a tweet at Deepak.
I will be monitoring.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this,